my talk of the table is tennis superstar
venus williams love her this seven-time
grand slam winner did you hear that
seven times has fought for women to get
equal pay throughout her legendary
career now in honor of women's history
month williams and her company 11 are
spearheading spearheading rather the
privileged tax initiative to draw
attention to the gender pay gap listen
to these numbers white women in this
country make 82 cents for every dollar
men do
that men made in 2020 and the gap is
even greater for women of color oh no
during this campaign people who buy
something from participating companies
can choose to donate a dollar at
checkout 100 did you get that part 100
of the proceeds go to the nonprofit
group girls inc which works to create
more opportunities for girls it's a
great organization and recently rightly
honored venus williams tina fey and some
others venus williams it's so good to
see you hello hello hello so you have
been fighting this battle for me hi
everybody good morning good morning
you've been fighting this fight for a
very long time did you at did did you
have a i'm mad as hell and i'm not going
to take it anymore a moment that you
finally said okay that's enough because
i'm thinking about the letter that you
wrote back in the wimbledon days to say
this ain't right
yeah i
came into inequality at the young age of
16 when i played my first grand slam and
that's a rude awakening
so i don't want any other young women to
have to face that you have the stats up
there
women are earning 82
on the dollar 82 cents the dollar that
men are earning and if you're a minority
if you're living out of the country of
usa that it gets even worse so
it's important to call attention to this
that people know this because women not
only need equal opportunity but it gives
them opportunity to grow
and become strong and to help their
families and all these things are so
important
no you wrote back in 2006 uh to the new
york times with power and status comes
responsibility wimbledon has power and
status the time has come for them to do
the right thing by paying men and women
the same prize money and you were the
first woman venus who got the same prize
money as the man roger federer at the
time what were your thoughts back then
when that happened did you say okay
finally finally
but we're still having this conference
exactly it was a conversation we'd been
having for 30 years and we'd be rejected
there over 30 years when we talked the
grand slam committee so many amazing
things have happened since that time
recently we saw women's soccer
uh garner equal pay so that was a super
exciting time now it's women's history
month and so it's a very important time
to talk about this and i partnered with
my activeweb brand 11 to create an
initiative called privilege tax where we
talk about this very subject we have
some amazing partners like you had on
the screen tracy anderson wta charities
captivate and i've also partnered with
credit karma as well on this to make
sure that companies that are giving
resources time education to their
managers to make sure they're not hiring
with biases to make sure they're giving
leadership opportunities to women and i
love that companies like credit karma
have taken that opportunity to make that
happen in their organization but there's
got to be more organizations and people
do want to do this but it takes time it
doesn't happen overnight so that's why
we're talking about it so people know
and organizations can get involved
venus how you doing nate burleson here i
have to say this as a nfl player former
nfl player
i would look up to you because you stood
for so much so much more than your sport
you transcended tennis and now as a
father of a young girl i want to say i
appreciate you because you are one of
the women that i point to and tell her
you can accomplish anything not just
what people tell you you can do
but you also know that that sexism isn't
just
a woman's issue
how can men get involved and help you
know change what is this gap in payment
and wage
absolutely and i'm so excited to partner
with girls inc a national organization
that helps girls to be bold and strong
and girls need to know that they have
these same opportunities
and it's just so important that this
happens so
i'm very excited i forgot part of the
question now
i'm sorry how can men be out what are we
talking about yeah how can how can men
be allies how can we get
involved helping because that was an
important question
we're here to help being important so
yeah thank you i need it it's early for
me i'm not an early riser
it's important because
men's like you said you men are the
fathers men are the husbands we're the
brothers
we're
those are our moms those are our friends
those are our colleagues men are an
integral part of this solution and at
this moment there are definitely more
men in power than women i just read a
statistic that there's eight percent of
women that are ceos of fortune 500
companies so men it's important that men
are part of the solution and
part of this conversation and actually
taking a role in leading this so so
important i love that you asked that
venus it's vlad
the pay gap is even
worse it's more stark for black women
how has your experience as a black woman
shaped your perspective on this issue
absolutely it is very true that that gap
widens when you're a black woman a woman
of minority
and it's important that we talk about
that as well
i'm just very happy that as an
african-american woman that i can speak
to this and make this known so it's a
very important role that i never thought
i'd play i i just wanted to win
wimbledon i got there it wasn't equal
and it's just led me to just this place
where i'm able to do more than i ever
could have thought i could do
for myself it's just it's just been a
dream to be a part of it to be honest
and and you are still doing it you know
the oscars are sunday night venus
williams who you rooting for in the best
actor category
maybe will
smith wilson said playing your dad was
one of the great honors of his life and
to sit at the table with you when he won
a big award recently he said was one of
the highlights of his career i'm
wondering if your dad has seen the movie
and what he thought and if you're going
to be going to the oscars
yeah i'm so happy to call will not only
the person who's memorialized my family
story but also my friend
and he just portrayed my dad so closely
there were moments and you know all this
was filmed during covets there'll be
moments where we were listening to the
live stream or watching the live stream
being filmed and i would hear my dad's
voice and it was so it gave me
goosebumps how close he got to my father
and of course we can't forget and anjanu
and how she could play german my mom
got it so right we cannot forget the
conversation then the girls who learned
to play tennis that's not easy to do
they learned and they made it realistic
and i'm so excited that we can share
this moment at the oscars i think they
knew we went has your dad seen the movie
did your dad see the movie did he watch
yeah you know my dad and i we don't talk
a lot about tennis but he's definitely
really proud of what has been part of
the film it's weird we don't talk about
work but no he's very proud
all right venus williams thank you we
are always cheering you on thank you so
much for coming on this morning thanks a
lot thank you